hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan cider
we're gonna review the trailer today for
evolve it's the launch trailer begging
16 thank you baby
hello Tara wow it's like Pacific Rim
you
oh sweet that's my place
really smoothly medical
god damn
sure
but yes
Wow
it works that way
ever buy
I [ __ ] love that logo I'm sorry just
not like a design for it would yeah dude
yeah that's [ __ ] hot dude it's do
that guy my heart pumping and my bowels
blowing wait what no I I just love it it
looks like Pacific Rim then you get a
play as the monsters or you could be the
one of the heroes and the heroes just
looks so badass like I want to be
immersed in this world this world looks
awesome to be a part of it's a freaking
cool concept now granted I've only
played the Alpha mm-hmm and I tried to
play the beta but if you got in a group
with three or three people you couldn't
connect to a game at least on Steam it
was bad from what I've seen it's awesome
and I got a chance to play as both the
monster in the hunters and being the
monster is the [ __ ] best thing is it
now so it is fun oh yeah totally I was
worried that be less long as I'd be like
yeah what the [ __ ] it was a little bit
easier I mean granted if you play it
right you can wreck them at least for
what I played it's very interesting
because like they're still they were
still trying to figure out the balance
of it but if your team was not like
[ __ ] spot-on like synced you were
toast and then as the monster you just
kind of burnin ate him and it was the
best thing knowing that you played this
makes me a lot more confident everything
I saw I loved it it looks exactly like I
just kept that you Pacific Rim don't do
yeah don't know that's like yeah this is
awesome they got like genuinely cool
designs of monsters I love good monster
design a lot I really do because you can
go wrong a lot of the time with a
monster design and others they're meant
to be scary yeah these creatures are
scary on first glance the Kraken the
little guy who we have things he's
[ __ ] hard to kill all of them with
anyway guys yeah they should tell me
that trailer was out if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects dan has a gaming channel
really do check that out it's one of the
best gaming channels I've ever seen not
just saying that
really is a good channel also you can
catch me playing evolve if you don't
mind me plug in the game I have a video
of me playing evolve do you say plug in
the game plugging me game I played the
game there's one of me playing as the
monster please go check it out Chris
Snyder hi Zack Snyder's a twin brother
and what who is not as famous oh we're
nowhere near Ryan I love your videos
always honest and natural reactions in
you're a very funny guy thanks I work
hard to put on a natural reaction but
people say you got good reactions I'm
like thanks requires no work on my end
to do that some people usually throw
baseball at their face and just like
hits him in the face and go I feel like
why don't you react faster oh I guess I
have bad reactions true silence mode my
reflex
i watch eat you on good days and bad and
even on my bad you always make me laugh
oh so well done to you sir and all the
other rejects I'm hoping I heard a shout
out Chris Snyder goddamn right he earned
a shout out I don't care that zach is
kind of a dick to you Chris just do your
own thing if you want to be a director
know you'll always be in your brother's
shadow but but if you want to anything
else you still might be your brother
Shep you're a little [ __ ] I'm sorry
Chris I should be really nice to you
right now but I I just got to be honest
with you hey tell you what you just okay
here's here's the high five just kind of
slap your hand against the screen way to
go is your computer okay it's your
computer [ __ ] okay rotting your brain
films hmm narcissistic mother [ __ ]
hey Ryan and the crew of the real
rejects I've been watching your channel
for a few months now and now have n have
been looking forward to your reaction
videos I wonder if you could give me a
shout-out to byb films it's a new
channel on YouTube your shout out will
be much appreciated thanks B YB films
wait what is it B YP b YB films yeah I
feel like he's only mentioned in like 14
[ __ ] times of this damn comment
be three maybe 20 you decide rot in your
brain films um you know what man
real quick let's find him let's find
this [ __ ]
are you girl it's totally a girl we got
a girl that watches the channel it's
black or Indian doesn't matter she's
[ __ ] cute brought in your films is
one of the best channels I've ever seen
if you guys don't subscribe to broader
your films it would be okay if I like
watch her videos right yeah like it's
not cheating on my girlfriend and some
like emotional lip no okay just making
sure
are you just making sure byb films are
you gonna replace her everyone else's
character dialogue with you speaking to
her softly be an interesting life very
sad and last note I had the intention of
reading this book I'm about a hundred
pages in and I've decided this is taking
way too long to get [ __ ] interesting
I am done